[Music]
I lost my parents
that pain
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
of your monkey you lost both parents in
one day very
my parents
instead
I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die
future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you fight God
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
these scars would have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no extra tragedy to find you
no matter what we do
we're not going to be able to fix this
no
nobody dies
you're strapped to your parachutes and
where's yours
wow